prompting increased scrutiny and demands
for transparency from republicans on
capitol hill joining us for reaction
former energy secretary and texas
governor rick perry mr secretary great
to see you as always you know joe biden
has the reverse midas touch
um
you know if he touches gold it turns to
stone
uh you know his profligate spending his
war on energy drove up prices of
everything at the gas pumps at the
grocery stores
it will only grow worse will it not
unless he reverses course and he ain't
going to reverse course so it's only
going to get more dire for americans
yeah it's
it's frankly
very disheartening
to watch
an individual who is supposed to be
trying to make america
a better place to live
that he has such disregard for
the average citizen out there you know i
i it's probably been decades since he
pulled into a gas station and bought a
gallon of gasoline
he doesn't understand
what the average citizen is going
through the cost of groceries going to
the grocery store trying to decide
whether you know do i fill the car up or
do i fill it halfway up and try to buy
some groceries all of those things are
going on with the american citizen today
he can get up and read what's on the
teleprompter or attempt to read what's
on the teleprompter
and do whatever his staff says
but the fact is the american people know
that it's his policies uh it's what he
said during the campaign that he hated
the fossil fuel industry he's going to
do everything he could to stop it and
he's doing that
and the cost to the american people
this fallacy that the left is put its
arms around uh and i guess will go
completely off the cliff that fossil
fuels are bad
that's got to be stopped the american
people have to stand back and say you
know what fossil fuels are at the core
of our ability to create wealth in this
country for us to have a flourishing
economy and for the rest of the world to
enjoy that at some point in time in the
future these you know net zero by 20 50
people like john kerry at out
they are saying to the rest of the world
the citizens of the world who don't have
access to power and electricity today we
don't care about you sorry you're gonna
die
i
have to what a
black-hearted people that is
i have to ask you about the
the president made a big deal that he
was going to tap the strategic petroleum
reserve to help out americans to lower
gas prices instead
we now find out he was secretly
diverting millions of barrels of oil to
the communist chinese and in particular
a company that reportedly his own son
hunter biden invested in
uh i mean if that doesn't strike you as
corruption and wrongdoing i don't know
what does
what do you think
greg
tapping the strategic petroleum reserve
it's there for a natural disaster or a a
national defense issue it's not there to
play economics with and the idea that
that you can it's it's not that much i
mean we're talking um a relatively small
amount in the grand scheme of things
from the standpoint of refining what he
should be doing is sending the message
to the country to the oil and gas
industry listen we're not going to over
regulate you we're not going to over tax
you
send the message to the refining
industry that we're going to do what we
can to be able to use american energy if
you care about the future you've got to
be for american fossil fuels secretary
perry thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else